this is my first time in Davos because
watched earlier meetings on television
but it's interesting to be here yes one
thing that really stands out is no
matter which conference I attend there
seems to be very close to a consensus on
many issues there are one or two
dissenters here and there but generally
when I just economy the environment
politics people seem to agree that right
now a repeat crisis and it is
self-evident of course but also that
this time it's really brought home to
everyone that everything is
interconnected this seems to be con talk
about one thing without having in fact
amount of the area that's been very
interesting to watch I also had a chance
to watch some kids yesterday especially
I think some of those because from
Malawi the young speakers from Allah we
really made an impact and it's been
great from